Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In 2017, scientists at OpenAI published a
paper where virtual humans learned to tackle
each other in a sumo competition of sorts,
and found out how to rock a stable stance
to block others from tackling them.
This was a super interesting work because
it involved self-play, or in other words,
copies of the same AI were playing against
each other, and the question was, how do we
pair them with each other to maximize their
learning.
They found something really remarkable when
they asked the algorithm to defeat an older
version of itself.
If it can reliably pull that off, it will
lead to a rapid and predictable learning process.
This kind of curriculum-driven learning can
supercharge many different kinds of AIs.
For instance, this robot from a later paper
is essentially blind as it only has proprioceptive
sensors, which means that the only thing that
the robot senses is its own internal state
and that’s it.
No cameras, depth sensors, no LIDAR, nothing.
And at first, it behaves as we would expect
it…look, when we start out, the agent is
very clumsy and can barely walk through a
simple terrain… but as time passes, it grows
to be a little more confident, and with that,
the terrain also becomes more difficult over
time in order to maximize learning.
That is a great life lesson right there.
So, how potent is this kind of curriculum
in teaching the AI?
Well, it learned a great deal in the simulation,
and as scientists deployed it into the real
world, just look at how well it traversed
through this rocky mountain, stream, and not
even this nightmarish snowy descent gave it
too much trouble.
This new technique proposes a similar curriculum-based
approach where we would teach all kinds of
virtual lifeforms to navigate on stepping
stones.
The examples include a virtual human, a bipedal
robot called cassie, and…this sphere with
toothpick legs too.
The authors call it “monster”, so, you
know what, monster it is.
So, the fundamental question here is, how
do we organize the stepping stones in this
virtual environment to deliver the best teaching
to this AI?
We can freely choose the heights and orientations
of the upcoming steps, and…of course, it
is easier said than done.
If the curriculum is too easy, no meaningful
learning will take place, and if gets too
difficult too quickly, well…then…in the
better case, this happens…and in the worst
case, whoops!
This work proposes an adaptive curriculum
that constantly measures how these agents
perform, and creates challenges that progressively
get harder, but in a way that they can be
solved by the agents.
It can even deal with cases where the AI already
knows how to climb up and down, and even deal
with longer steps.
But that does not mean that we are done, because
if we don’t build these spirals right, this
happens.
But, after learning 12 to 24 hours with this
adaptive curriculum learning method, they
become able to even run, deal with huge step
height variations, high step tilt variations,
and let’s see if they can pass the hardest
exam…look at this mess, my goodness, lots
of variation in every parameter.
And…Yes!
It works!
And the key point is that the system is general
enough that it can teach different body types
to do the same.
If there is one thing that you take home from
this video, it shouldn’t be that it takes
from 12 to 24 hours.
It should be that the system is general.
Normally, if we have a new body type, we need
to write a new control algorithm, but in this
case, whatever the body type is, we can use
the same algorithm to teach it.
Absolutely amazing.
What a time to be alive!
However, I know what you’re thinking.
Why teach them to navigate just stepping stones?
This is such a narrow application of locomotion,
so why this task?
Great question, and the answer is that the
generality of this technique we just talked
about also means that the stepping stone navigation
truly was just a stepping stone, and here
it is - we can deploy these agents to a continuous
terrain and expect them to lean on their stepping
stone chops to navigate well here too.
Another great triumph for curriculum-based
AI training environments.
So what do you think?
What would you use this technique for?
Let me know in the comments, or if you wish
to discuss similar topics with other Fellow
Scholars in a warm and welcoming environment,
make sure to join our Discord channel.
The link is available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!